hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a South Korean crime Thriller
film called Memories of murder spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
it is October of 1986 the movie is set
in the huysong province of South Korea
where a woman has been found dead near a
field the cops are immediately informed
by the villagers and head detective Park
Dumont arrives at the scene he checks
inside a sewer and finds the decomposing
body of the victim it is clear that she
was treated inappropriately before her
murder after inspecting the scene dumon
returns to the station and starts
interrogating various suspects for the
crime however the process is very
tedious as he uses a typewriter dumon
takes pictures of all the suspects and
Kwan kiok a female detective arranges
them in a book he stares them in their
eyes as he believes he can identify the
perpetrator through eye contact just
then they are informed that another
woman has been murdered in the same area
dumon rushes to the scene and finds a
footprint which he assumes can serve as
a clue unfortunately before he can have
a better look at it a tractor drives
over the footprint and destroys it as a
result Dumont ends up back at the
station without any evidence collected I
hope he arrested that tractor several
months passed by and it appears as if
the case has gone cold but one day dumon
learns from his girlfriend that bayak a
mentally scarred handicapped boy had
been stalking the second victim before
her death finally finding a clue he
immediately brings bayak to the station
and interrogates him then dumon along
with another colleague beat him up
mercilessly they try to force a
confession out of him but the poor guy
only admits that he was stalking her in
the next scene a man is seen approaching
a woman on a silent Road he tries asking
for directions to a certain place but
she does not respond this is because
everyone in the town has become
terrified due to the recent murder cases
the woman tries to run away but only
ends up falling in a heap just then
dumon appears and instantly jumps on the
man assuming that he is attacking the
girl later he learns that the man is
xyota Yoon a detective from Seoul who
has volunteered to assist with the case
on their way to the station do man goes
to the crime scene makes a footprint
with bayak's shoes and takes a picture
he then goes back to the station and
tries to beat a confession out of bayak
this time however he shows the photos of
the fake shoe Prince despite this baek
still denies being related to the murder
Fed Up the detectives take bayak to a
field and threaten to bury him alive so
the latter hesitantly starts explaining
what happened that day he reveals that
the victim was strangled with her bra
first and then tied with her stockings
so far this all sounds hot bayak when do
things start going downhill hearing this
the detectives are shocked as back then
in Korea crimes like murder and physical
assault were less prevalent they demand
to know more but when bayek says I don't
know they start beating the hell out of
him the next day bayak is declared the
Killer and is taken for a spot
inspection in front of the reporters
fortunately tyun arrives in the nick of
time and interrupts them he checks by X
hands which are severely scarred and
asserts that there is no possible way he
could have tied the knots around his
victims hearing this the villagers
realized that bayak is Being Framed and
so they attack the officers they are
willing to support their local friend no
matter what in the following scene we
are introduced to tyun's new colleague
Shin dong Chul who has been transferred
to lead their team dong shul gets
straight to work and asks the other
officers if there were any similarities
between the murders however they're
speechless simply because they have
spent their entire time framing an
innocent man when they could have gone
after the real killer fortunately the
smart guy tyun briefs them that all the
murders happen during rainy days and the
victims wore red clothes then dongjul
asks if both the victims died the same
way too but tyun's answer surprises all
of them he reveals that there were three
victims among which one is yet to be
found it turns out that in the past week
a third girl who was wearing red clothes
went missing on a rainy day in no time
the third body is found and tyun is
proven right the police then confirmed
the murder pattern in regard of the case
as a serial killing since the cases have
too many similarities dongchul suggests
they prepare for the time it rains as
that is when the Killer is likely to
strike one day while the detectives are
helping suppress a student Rebellion it
suddenly starts raining all of them get
ready to implement the plan the female
detective kui awk dresses in red and
walks around the area where the murders
took place hoping to lure the killer
unfortunately even after hours of
waiting no one arrives hence the
detective said to a checkpost where they
meet two schoolgirls one of them tells a
story about an assumed killer who
apparently hides in the toilet
throughout the day and only comes out at
night stiff competition for Oscar the
Grouch as expected the detectives find
the story hilarious and they simply
laugh it off meanwhile we see a lady at
home listening to the radio when she
gets a call the person on the other end
asks her to immediately visit him the
lady who is wearing a red jacket decides
to switch it hoping she doesn't get
attacked once she gets out of her house
she starts humming a song to keep
herself distracted but just as she
reaches the fields she hears someone
whistling which makes her stop in her
tracks the woman knows what's lurking in
the dark so she attempts to make a run
for it unfortunately before she can call
for help a man suddenly pounces on her
the next day the detectives find her
lifeless body the rainy day Toilet Boy
strikes again just like the others she
has been strangled to death with her own
undergarments later at the police
station kuyak insinuates that she has
something important to show she brings
what looks like a list of songs played
on the radio and reveals that the same
song was played every time a murder
occurred kuyak further discloses that a
person requested the song to be played
on rainy days which coincidentally
matched the murder dates Dumont just
laughs it off which is ridiculous what
kind of detective does Dumont think he
is but dongchul and taiyoon look for
information regarding it hoping to find
the postcard with the song request
taiyoon goes to the radio station but
ends up disappointed as they have
already thrown it away Dumont on the
other hand goes to the crime scene with
one of his colleagues Yoon ho and
spreads a Talisman around believing that
the perpetrator's face will appear on it
after it dries just then they hear some
footsteps approach prompting them to
hide in the bushes the two believe that
it is the murderer but to their dismay
tayune has arrived to inspect the scene
but suddenly they hear another person
approaching so tayune also hides on the
other side after a while a man appears
and starts pleasuring himself to a
woman's lingerie probably just a
coincidence the detectives witnessed
this and become disgusted just as Yoon
ho is ready to move he accidentally
makes a sound that alerts the man
prompting him to run away the detectives
also run after him and eventually catch
him near a construction site after
taking the Pervert into custody they
question him mercilessly however the man
claims that he didn't murder anyone he
was only fulfilling one of his sick
fantasies as the investigation continues
the detectives find out that the Pervert
is actually a very diligent person who
takes good care of his family outside of
the villagers find out about it and
start protesting for the release of the
man they are fed up with police
brutality and discrimination hey let us
be perverts you guys yeah let us kill
people I mean let us be perverts yeah
frustrated at the end investigation is
going nowhere taiyoon goes to meet the
girls who told him about the rumored
murderer hiding in public toilets after
talking to them he goes to the said
toilet and finds a woman there initially
she doesn't open the door but when tyun
mentions that he is a detective she
agrees to help the woman then leads him
to a house where the rumors began it
belongs to an extremely terrified lady
who is a survivor of a similar attack
tayune listens to her story and realizes
that the lady was also attacked by the
serial killer they are looking for
however the only useful piece of
information he learns is that the
perpetrator had very soft hands so he
rushes back to the station and checks
the pervert's hands when he confirms
that they are not soft he lets the
innocent man go much to the annoyance of
Dumont just then kuyak turns on the
radio where the murderer's song is
playing coincidentally it has started
raining as well realizing that a murder
is about to take place kuyak rushes to
the radio station to get the postcard
unfortunately just after an hour they
find another dead body she has something
stuck in her private part in his a small
piece of Peach on the other hand cuyak
finally finds the postcard at the radio
station and learns that it belongs to
hyongyu a factory worker they
immediately take him into custody and
the first thing taiyoon does is check
his hands surprisingly it fits the
description as they are really soft they
then interrogate him and mentioned that
the killing started happening after he
moved to that place hyongyu admits to
sending the postcards but denies killing
anyone he tells them that he won't fall
into confessing about something he
didn't do this angers the detectives but
they can't punish him owing to the fact
that they already have a bad reputation
among the general public when they
confront him about the peaches he on you
starts getting uncomfortable and lashes
out at them assuming he is the killer
Yoon who gets mad and beats him to a
pulp resulting in his own expulsion from
the case now that the team is again back
to square one they decide to follow up
on all their previous Clues again when
they play by X confession they finally
realize that he explained the incident
as a bystander so the detectives make
their way to bayek's Family Restaurant
on reaching there they find it
intoxicated yoon-hill who gets into a
fight with random people suddenly bayak
arrives at the scene and hits you know
with a wooden board that pierces his leg
with a rusty nail realizing what he has
done bayek flees and unintentionally
arrives at the scene of the first murder
soon dumon and tyun also arrive they
Again Begin coercing him for more
information bayek finally gives in and
tells them that he saw the Killer's face
three times thinking that they are close
to solving the case they show him
hyongyu's picture but bayek instead
starts rambling about a house fire
suddenly an angry mob of villagers
approaches the detectives to teach them
a lesson this scares poor bayak and he
starts running here and there aimlessly
unfortunately he doesn't notice an
approaching train and gets struck
resulting in an instant death the next
day with the news all over the police
station gets a lot of calls one of them
is from the forensics lab revealing that
a semen sample was found the only
problem is that the technology in Korea
is too primitive to inspect it this
comes too mysterious sir so they have to
send the semen sample to the U.S and
wait for the results meanwhile Duman
gets some devastating news from the
hospital it turns out Yoon Ho's leg has
to be amputated due to the spread of
tetanus caused by the rusty nail
somewhere else a woman is on her way to
work she is walking extremely cautiously
because of the news she's been hearing
lately shortly after a schoolgirl walks
past her despite the scary situation the
two don't even interact with one another
suddenly a man approaches the schoolgirl
from behind and takes her away he then
ties her up does mean things to her and
finishes her off brutally the next day
tyun rushes towards the scene filled
with reporters the body of the
schoolgirl has been found and by the
looks of it the culprit is yet again the
serial killer taiyun realizes that the
victim is the same girl who directed him
to the toilet woman devastated that he
couldn't help her he dashes towards
hyungu and starts beating him up tyun
also brings out his gun ready to finish
him off but just then Dumont appears
with the DNA results of the semen it
reveals that he is actually innocent
with this the detectives are once again
back to square one with no clues of who
the murderer is so a few days later the
case is eventually closed the movie then
skips to the year 2003 where dumon is
having breakfast with his family he has
now retired from the force and has
become a successful businessman one day
he goes to the same crime scene which
was once filled with the dead bodies of
women Duman looks at the drain where he
found the first body when suddenly a
little girl walks up to him she reveals
that another man was checking the drain
some time ago just like him the movie
ends as a shocked dumon looks at the
camera realizing that the killer may
still be around the movie is based on a
true story about South Korea's first
serial killer in total he killed 15
women and the case remained unsolved for
30 long years when memories of murder
was released the case was still a
mystery but in 2020 using the help of
Advanced Medical forensics the killer
was finally revealed to be
he is now serving a life sentence too
bad they couldn't catch him earlier so
this movie could have a satisfying
ending subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching